let's talk a little bit about jerome
powell trying to crash bitcoin what's
going on there john
yeah jerome powell is meeting with the
house financial services committee on
the state of the economy this week he
met yesterday um on wednesday and he's
meeting today on thursday um and he's
just talking about
different things
different things that's going on the
economy whether that's inflation whether
that's rate hikes whether that's uh the
global reserve currency that's the
sanctions on russia and how it all kind
of plays into the economy we have going
on today um so our first thing is we
have a tweet john powell's online uh he
is currently saying that usd is
currently system with high liquidity
it's the place to be is a quote from him
um and then from an economy and or from
an ecosystem an economy for an
alternative where were to evolve another
reserve currency could emerge it's
possible to have more than one reserve
currency i completely agree it is
possible to have more than one reserve
currency but what is that currency going
to be are they going to try to make it a
cbdc are they going to try to make it
bitcoin um
gold could do we see us going back to
gold like what is the other reserve
currency i think is what's on people's
minds but i completely agree that we can
have two reserve currencies um it's just
got to be the right one usd has
obviously fallen off and then we have a
quote from jerome powell here that said
the ukraine russia conflict underscored
the need for congressional actions on
digital finance including
cryptocurrencies we have this burgening
burgeoning
industry which has many parts to it and
there isn't in place the kind of
regulatory framework that needs to be
there let's talk about the framework
around bitcoin and what regulations need
to be put into place to maybe stop
russia from living sanctions with
bitcoin which we talked about yesterday
but also just like what needs to be in
place to kind of regulate this industry
so it's not the wild west anymore so
countries aren't just setting up
accounts or is that the right thing and
we kind of allow that um so just setting
up our infrastructure in a place and our
regulation in a place that people can
move forward and innovate on this
technology yeah he also talked about uh
how terrorists or other people doing bad
things just bad actors can use
cryptocurrency uh as a means to skirt
the system and get around things and
this is a narrative as old as time right
we've talked about this literally a
hundred times on this show alone which
is that criminals do not want to use the
blockchain because everything can be
traced everything is visible everything
is transparent it is much easier to
catch people right if you're the fbi if
you're the dea if you're uh a government
agency in general you want people to use
bitcoin you want people to use a means
of transaction that you can be traced it
can be transparent it can be looked at
and overviewed so that makes no sense to
me at all i agree there needs to be
regulatory framework just go do it
literally go do it we've been waiting
for this forever now to just have
regulatory clarity and what we've seen
is people and their companies and their
corporations are going to places around
the world where there is clarity it
doesn't have to be the best laws in the
world maybe it's the worst laws in the
world it doesn't really matter in my
mind but as long as there's clarity it
makes it much more important so people
know exactly what to expect if you want
to go mind somewhere you need to know
exactly what to expect from a regulatory
perspective when you're going there if
you want to own an exchange somewhere
you need to know exactly where you're
going to expect and if the united states
wants to be the king when it comes to
bitcoin and the digital asset industry
they need to be very very very very
clear about what's going to happen from
a regulatory standpoint they need to do
it quick and they need to do it in a uh
in a good manner right we want to be
kind to people we want to innovate here
we want to do what we've always done
which is entice entrepreneurs to come
build their companies in our country and
ultimately what we're going to see is
the country that does that the best is
going to entice people to come there and
it's a massive industry there's going to
be massive tax benefits there's going to
be massive jobs there's going to be
massive things from a regulatory
standpoint and it's going to lift up
entire regions at a time we're seeing
this now on a country level countries
like el salvador or nation states like
el salvador and others and
around the world ukraine now they all
own bitcoin right they're buying bitcoin
i'm sure as hell other countries are
doing it this week also just given the
nature of exactly what's happening in
the dependence that they're seeing uh
what can happen when you depend on the
us dollar or another currency around the
world so ultimately i think it comes
down to jerome powell like let's figure
it out i think people agree people want
regulatory clarity it doesn't have to be
the best it doesn't have to be the worst
but just give us clarity around exactly
what can happen i don't think it's fair
to just say hey look terrorists use this
and therefore we should regulate the
hell out of it because everyone knows
when it comes to terrorism when it comes
to drugs when it comes to other illegal
activities the u.s dollar is still the
preferred currency of choice i think
it's about two to five percent 800 or so
billions of dollars of every each year
is used for illicit activities here in
the united states
or within the u.s dollar that is much
much much more than digital currencies
and bitcoin the the number with bitcoin
has actually been declining over time it
has become obvious that it is not the
currency of choice when it comes to
criminals and it should not be used for
illicit activities so i think ultimately
what we're going to find is that this is
going to continue to reduce over time
people do not want to use bitcoin and
other digital assets as a means of uh of
doing illegal things jerome powell i
think understands that i think he is
playing one side of the ball right now
and saying we need to regulate this but
ultimately most bitcoiners agree would
you agree john
i would agree i think more and more
people have realized that the public uh
transparency of bitcoin and the bitcoin
ledger
are just not good for doing illicit
activities we saw the we were talking
about yesterday the bitfinex 2016 hack
they easily traced it right the
government has uh and all governments
around the world have been getting
better and better at kind of tracking
um those bad actors within an industry
right so 50 of cash money laundering
goes undetected bitcoin it's easily
available to see where the funds are
going where have they been uh what walls
have they gone through what systems have
they gone through and then where they
end up in the end what bank do they get
transferred to in the end how do people
actually pull out their money uh which
is i think the big mishap for a lot of
people
but yeah look uh the fed also talked
about an interest rate hike which i
think the market is kind of pricing in
right now um they're talking about uh 25
basis point interest rate hike so 0.25
percent
money's getting more expensive the
market's going down because of it and
also because of all the uncertainty
that's happening in the world right when
you have the chairman of the federal
reserve saying hey there could be
another global reserve currency uh when
the only global reserve currency right
now is the united states dollar that is
concerning for the united states dollar
that's concerning for the u.s markets
are they going to try to introduce
another one and kind of build one from
scratch with the cbdc do they just say
hey we're actually going to use gold as
well which russia has been accumulating
massive amounts of over the last decade
so like what do they do like what it
what are they trying to signal by saying
this is uh there's going to be another
global reserve currency or there could
be another global reserve currency um it
really just depends how our government
treats it and what where we go to from
here um but it looks like the us dollar
is in a very very strong place still
doesn't look like it's going anywhere um
and then over time people i think will
begin
to um people will begin to realize that
there are
available options for another global
reserve currency and then powell said
here
uh peter schiff said here in a tweet
powell said he still supports a
one-fourth point rate hike at the march
meeting and will start
working on a plan to begin shrinking the
balance sheet at some unknown future
date the fact that such a plan doesn't
already exist proves the fed has no real
intention of carrying one out especially
saying the fed has the fed has no idea
what's going on they're going to do a 25
25 base point hike uh but the fact that
they don't know when or or uh how it
will like kind of go just speaks to they
don't really understand what's going on
they don't really have a plan to start
with hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time